so the champions right they're these
super cool people that function kind of
like a cross between the sages of past
zelda titles and the hero himself link
in that they're kind of
mini heroes who assist link but not by
just you know warping to some remote
location and sending their thoughts and
prayers to link and zelda but by
actually
physically helping to beat ganon to a
pulp and they're awesome
well uh most of them anyway each of
these champions were selected according
to the creating a champion literature
because they possessed unique abilities
rivali has the power to create strong
updrafts
daruk has the power to create an
impenetrable force field mifa has the
power to heal
wounds and urbosa has the power to
control lightning itself
and in the case of the present day young
goron hero named yunobo
who actually is a descendant of daruk
the force field ability called daruk's
protection was passed down to him
genetically through the champion's
bloodline
all well and good but it begs the
question how did daruc's protection come
to be
in the first place or any of the powers
for that matter
how did herbosa become able to
manipulate lightning or mifa to reverse
the negative effects of physical ailment
also known as healing
did the champions one day all of a
sudden just possess these abilities out
of the blue or
is it possible that these abilities were
actually created
long ago before the events of the first
great calamity
10 000 years ago to answer that question
let's first determine
everything we know about the behavior of
the champion's abilities
like i already mentioned before these
abilities are unique to the champions
and in one case a champion's direct
descendant
but are also present in a completely
different set of
individuals if you will you see in the
last theory video i uploaded i talked
about the fact that the blight ganons
inexplicably are able to use the
champion's abilities
which by the way if you haven't seen yet
take a moment and pause this video right
here and check it out because i'm about
to expound upon that idea and it may
sound a little confusing if you haven't
heard the first theory yet i'll place a
link to it in the description below and
on the screen anyway in a nutshell i
speculated that the blight ganons were
able to use the champion's abilities
because they were
the champions themselves or at least
were able to infuse the champions into
themselves
after having defeated them 100 years ago
and without spoiling anything
the new game age of calamity kind of
confirms this
wind blight gannon can create tornadoes
of wind descend at you fire blight ganon
can straight up use daruk's protection
thunderblade ganon can call down
lightning like urbosa and water blight
ganon can create and manipulate water
and wields a spear like
mifa each of these are clearly inspired
by the champions they defeated 100 years
ago but i'm not going to talk about how
that may have happened in this video
that was the last video's job instead we
have to wonder at what this
actually means for the origin of the
champion's abilities the champions and
the blight ganons have something in
common that would allow them both to
wield these powers but i'll get right
back to this a bit later on
the first clue i think lies in the
abilities names
rivali's gail mifa's grace daruk's
protection and her
bose's fury do you see the pattern here
they're all named after the champions
of the second calamity if the champions
themselves had maybe inherited the
abilities due to their bloodlines
reaching
all the way back to the original four
champions of the first calamity which we
don't have any proof for
it wouldn't make much sense to name the
abilities after the champions of the
second calamity
and if they were named based on just
whoever currently uses the ability then
wouldn't deruk's protection
be called unibose protection now this
implies that the abilities might not
have existed before the second
calamity's champions did
otherwise their names might have been
something else entirely the second clue
is in the abilities icons
yes you heard me correctly they're icons
because even though the abilities
themselves are named after the champions
for some reason the pictures on the
icons are not instead the icons actually
depict the divine beasts of their
champions
now here's another question that brings
up why would the abilities icons depict
the beasts which they are indirectly
connected to why not a picture of the
champion's faces or maybe even their
champion's weapons to signify the
champion they're connected to
and named after now on the surface level
this may seem like an
insignificant little detail to
scrutinize over but when you're
designing a game from the ground up
like nintendo does with nearly every
zelda game everything is significant in
some way
and in this case we see that the
abilities are tied both in name
directly to the champions but also in
appearance to the divine beasts which
also implies that the abilities are
connected to the divine beast's creators
the sheikah in fact the icons also very
closely resemble the spirit orbs that
link receives from the sheikah monks and
the abilities themselves
when materialized are shown to be
transferred into link in almost the
exact same manner
flying through the air in a metaphysical
orb and being absorbed into link's chest
in both instances an individual gives
link a power-up that when absorbent to
his body
remains with him forever an exact
parallel of what can only be classified
as shika technology
now let's start piecing some of this
together excluding link we have the
second calamity champions the malice
gannons and unibo
as every known holder of the champion's
abilities what is the one thing that all
of these individuals have in common with
each other
the divine beasts the champions piloted
them the malice ganons also piloted them
and unibo is related to
a pilot now the divine beasts are pretty
special they're not like all the other
shika automations
they can't be programmed but rather must
be piloted like a horse or other animal
that you might ride upon
and the method of piloting a divine
beast is also pretty special because as
we see in game even though link can
control certain elements of the beasts
from his sheikah slate when he's
traversing through them
he can't actually take control of the
wheel and drive them around
there aren't any interfaces on any of
the divine beasts that look like they
could be a control room either
meaning these things aren't controlled
by physical means i think that we're
actually given some hints as to the
nature of their controls
every time we see a cutscene involving
the champion spirits as you can see the
champions actually talk to the divine
beasts
like they were oh i don't know alive or
at least possessing some sort of psychic
link to their pilots and it's more than
just that in daruk and mifa's cutscenes
they both make comments about wondering
how life is going outside of the divine
beasts
implying that though they may want to
they can never set foot outside them
this means that since their spirits can
only live inside the divine beasts
there's some sort of psychic
spiritual connection between the beasts
and their pilots now why am i going over
all this divine beast stuff
hold on i'm about to solidify the theory
what if
ten thousand plus years ago when the
sheikah scientists were making all this
awesome shika stuff
and the divine beasts themselves they
designed them to operate based off of
psychic abilities and gave them the
ability to connect spiritually to a
worthy pilot
and the way that a pilot would know they
were chosen is they would be gifted with
a special ability from the divine beast
itself the sheikah are 100 capable of
making technology that can determine
worthy champions
i mean the entire world of hyrule is
cluttered with shrine trials and when
the divine beasts and other shika
technologies were shunned by the highly
and royal family after the first
calamity and buried underneath the
ground
they eventually powered off and as we
know remained that way for 10
000 years preventing their champion
abilities from being seen by hyruleans
for that entire era
and then a little over a hundred years
ago when the king of hyrule ordered the
excavation of the ancient sheikah
technology which led to the unearthing
and powering on of the divine beasts
after
ten thousand years of stasis they once
again chose champions worthy of being
their pilots and gifted them with their
abilities
who we know of today as urbosa daruk
mifa and zelda falco
since most records of the divine beasts
and related sheika tech were old legends
at this point
the abilities that had previously been
forgotten were now heralded as
new abilities and then became named
after the champions they resided in
currently
so basically my theory in a nutshell is
that the champion's abilities were
created by the sheikah and given to the
divine beasts to then give to their
chosen champions i believe that through
the naming scheme and overall design of
the abilities appearances
this is what makes the most sense it is
also possible that the original
champions of the first calamity were
gifted these abilities directly
and these current champions of the
second calamity were simply their
descendants whose powers became awoken
after the divine beasts were unearthed
but either way even though the game
makes it seem like the champions had a
choice
in whether or not they would accept
zelda's proposal and be pilots
creating a champion directly states that
most of them were chosen because of
their abilities
meaning they probably didn't have much
of a choice either way now there are a
couple remaining questions to clear up
real quick about the abilities before i
end this video
such as why would unibo have daruk's
protection but riju not have her boss's
fury and why can't link pilot the divine
beasts after receiving their gifts for
the first one i think the ability was
duplicated when daruk had children
i mean it obviously was since yunobo and
link slash fireblack ganon
both have the ability in present time
the same goes for riju
since herbosa is stated to be her
ancestor as well but personally i think
that since riju is only 12 years
old it may be as simple as she just
hasn't unlocked the power yet or doesn't
know how to use it
similar to another young girl we know as
for link not being able to control the
divine beasts after receiving the
abilities
we actually don't really know for a fact
that he couldn't pilot them i mean it's
not like he ever tries to but even so i
think that after the abilities were
given to the champions
they could then be manipulated at will
and it wouldn't affect the spiritual tie
between the pilot and beast
case in point deruk's descended not
affecting his tie to varudanya but
that's all just my theory what do you
guys think are the champions abilities
sheik attack in nature or are they some
magical
something that we don't know of yet and
keep in mind that most magic is just
technology that hasn't been explained
yet
let me know in the comments below hey
guys thank you so much for watching
this one was a bit more speculation than
theory but it was still a bunch of fun
to work on
if you enjoyed it please consider
leaving a like to get it spread around
on the merciless algorithm of youtube
and if you happen to be a fan of the
legend of zelda and nintendo in general
maybe even subscribe to the channel to
stick around for the next video i
promise you it will be worth it as
always huge thanks to my fantastic
supporters who make my day
every single day if you're interested in
helping put food on the table here in
the banded house and also helping the
next video come to life
please feel free to check out that join
button listed below or follow the links
in the description to find out how
also down there are links to my social
media pages so come on over and say hi
on twitter that's all i've got for this
one so as always i hope you have a
wonderful rest of your day
this is masentino bandit signing out
[Music]
peace
you